[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily did police catch
a serial killer
four murders and three assaults in just
weeks stops texas police officers
in their tracks we do suspect
that he may be responsible for other
offenses and an iowa farmer admits to
raping and killing a jogger
so why is his defense requesting a
mental health evaluation
plus accusations against athletes what a
new report is accusing lsu football
players of doing
a boxer fails to pay up in a civil
sexual assault case
the victim's lawyer wants answers the
truth is we don't know what's true
where adrian broner is concerned
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
dallas police say a man arrested for at
least four motor murders
is quote the definition of a serial
killer
the motive on the salina murder uh
appears to be
that murder is against a family member
so that is the
that is the only offense that we have
seen that seems to have some sort of
connection or association between
the victim and the suspects
in my opinion based on what i've seen so
far
uh i believe that this is the definition
of a serial killer it's it's
it's random uh there is no known
association between victims
uh and and the complainant and uh
the the characteristics of the shooting
are similar he's always shooting out of
a
a vehicle but uh other than
there is no known motive outside of
those uh those characteristics and
behaviors of the
of the shooter
31 year old jeremy harris is accused of
being behind a violent crime spree in
texas
investigators say harris killed at least
four people and wounded three others
the salina fire department responded to
a house fire
and found the body of a 60 year old man
witnesses say they saw a suspect running
from the home
police also linked harris's vehicle to
the murders of a hip-hop artist
and a college student the first victim
is to believe to be
the father of the suspect's
ex-girlfriend while the other victims
appear to be
completely random so what we know about
him so far
is that he has a a minor criminal
history does have
a a an offense involving theft
i believe there's an offense involving
drugs and a family violence offense
nothing in the aggravated assault
robbery or murder range
we um we don't
have any real association or tied to any
type of extremist group
not incredibly active on social media
as far as why he may
what may have led him to this uh we we
haven't had the opportunity to interview
him
i don't know that any of that
information is
um is is is obvious through some of his
social media
and we have not had the opportunity to
interview as many witnesses
as we eventually well so we may learn
more as we move forward but at this
point
no real indicators of someone who would
commit these types of crimes
the wave of violence in the dallas area
prompted governor greg
abbott to deploy the texas state
troopers to assist the city with a
criminal investigation
we are uh we could not be more grateful
for having this individual out of our
community
the violence itself homicides and
aggravated assaults
uh put a certain level of fear in our
community to begin with
but the knowledge that someone is
randomly uh with no real
reason and reckless regard for human
life is going around
uh murdering murdering individuals is a
separate kind of fear
uh the the other homicides involve
individuals in some cases that know one
another
uh not that they are not significant but
it's a different level of fear
uh from walking out of your house and
believing that you're you're going to be
the subject of some random acts of
violence so we could not be more
uh happy for our community uh and to
make sure that we have uh this this
individual
off the streets uh committing these
heinous acts
all right joining me now is attorney
terry austin terry this one's a new one
for me serial killers
i get the first attack but the other
ones that god for saying are completely
random but
he's linked by his black chevy suv
talk to us about how the police are
connecting this case together
brian this is when forensics is going to
be your best friend they're going to
want to try to get
prince off of the vehicle obviously and
anywhere
the victims may have been to get prince
to sort of connect that back to this
individual they're going to look at
social media
so they're going to look at everything
circumstantial to sort of
tie it all back to him if at all
possible maybe he said something
you know online and they can sort of see
whether or not he's
trying to admit to some of this because
sometimes that is a motive so
forensics here i think is going to be
the key now
you kind of talked about from the
prosecutor's aspect from the defense
can you kind of see them pulling this
apart and saying hey maybe the first
murder but not the other ones
well absolutely i think the one thing
they're going to say is hey
this is random there is no connection
how are you putting
our defendant here yeah that's going to
be interesting to see how that plays out
of course they're saying they have some
forensic if you've highlighted the
possibility of dna we're just got to
wait and see how that plays out
as the evidence comes in and now to
another string of seemingly random
attacks this time in massachusetts
walton police have released surveillance
video
they say shows a suspect attacking 10
people
in three weeks victims report being
struck with a metal pipe from behind
one of the videos shows the suspect
walking away
and another shows them running police
are asking the public for help to
identify the suspect
here's another case we're following
closely on the law and crime network
terry austin has more
killing an arkansas woman out jogging is
requesting a mental health evaluation
attorneys for quake llewellyn say
there's reason to believe
he might not fully understand criminal
proceedings due to a mental
defect that he may have llewellyn is
accused of hitting
sydney southern with his car on the road
authorities say he confessed to moving
her body
raping and burying her a gps application
on the suspect's phone
led detectives to finding the victim's
body
all right defense attorneys are
requesting an evaluation
to determine his fitness to proceed in a
criminal
and potential criminal responsibility
terry
what does that mean fit to proceed
exactly
and if he's not fit to proceed what's
that mean for the case
you know it's a great question a
defendant has to be found
competent that means he has to
understand the nature and the
consequences of the proceedings against
him
if he isn't found competent then they
cannot bring the charges against him
and it's a good question they'll just
wait to see if he gets competent
all right it's going to be probably a
long wait especially in this time during
covet as
we're seeing so many cases waiting for
those medical evaluations
but of course we'll keep eyes on that
case and others still ahead on the law
and crime daily accusations of sexual
misconduct by athletes
from the football field to the boxing
ring where a judge is ordering a fighter
to put his money where his mouth
is and back to the court stay with us
[Music]
welcome back a judge in cleveland orders
a boxer back to court after he said he'd
be able to pay
800 000 to a woman he assaulted
with money that doesn't exist long
crimes angina levy is here to fill us in
on the details
nancy margaret russo she's already sent
adrian broner to jail for contempt
once before and she may send him to jail
yet again
this all comes as broner got a new
lawyer we told you earlier this month
that broner told the judge
that he was training for a big fight in
january he claimed he would earn five
million dollars for the fight
win or lose so he'd be able to pay the
judgment then
the judgment is for an assault on a
woman in 2018
at a nightclub broner was supposed to
produce the contract
for that fight last week his new lawyer
told the victim's lawyer there's
actually no fight in january
and it doesn't appear that there's five
million dollars coming
i certainly don't want to guess what a
judge will do
but i think the judge was very clear
that this was an order of the court this
was not a request
we don't have compliance and the court
has shown
let's just say a proclivity to trying to
hold broner accountable
although he does seem to be someone who
just doesn't comply with court
requirements
the attorney for the victim in this case
and he says that adrian broner has
actually been raising money to pay this
judgment
croner has put out a request that his
friends and supporters give him 13
apiece toward paying the judgment and if
his posts are correct
he seems to be suggesting that he's
already obtained about thirteen
thousand dollars supposedly toward
paying
the judgment and yet he hasn't paid a
dime toward the judgment
where is that money is he pocketing the
money he's asked for supporters to give
money on cash app
is he pulling yet another scam on the
public
adrian broner's new attorney did not
return my call today i was asking for an
interview both he and broner have been
ordered to appear at a hearing
in cleveland next monday the judge says
they need to show cause as to why she
should not hold both of them
in contempt and brian will of course
follow it and let you know what happens
i'm betting that both the defense
attorney and the defender are staying
off social media for a while but thank
you very much
for that reporting and jeanette uh for
legal analysis of this let's
bring back in terry austin uh attorney
and co-host
terry i'm going to take a page out of
eckland mercy's book i mean
stay off social media what are you doing
if this is your client
how furious are you with them right now
you're very furious because
the last thing you want to do is to have
your
client go on social media or do any sort
of
presser with you know the case pending
so
you could accidentally say something and
it's very important to make sure that
you have that conversation
so your client knows that they are not
supposed to be
saying things publicly like that that
could very well be used against them at
trial
now broader has already been held in
contempt of court based on previous
actions
so do you think with this case coming up
the next hearing is it a matter of
if or when he gets held in contempt
based on his actions here
you know i think he will be held in
contempt particularly if he continues
this type of behavior
the judge was very clear in saying that
she's not going to tolerate this
and so i think that both he and the
attorney
better make sure they're following the
orders of the court yeah it's going to
be very interesting to see how this
plays out
uh but how can the just quickly is the
lawyer in trouble as well or just the
defendant
i think they could both be in trouble
frankly if they don't listen to what the
court has to say
all right thanks there we'll see how
that plays out and when we come back
rape allegations against members of the
lsu football team
what the university officials are
accused of doing and not doing
plus a deeper dive into the ohio trial
involving a bitter custody dispute and a
fake pizza order
much more ahead
[Music]
from the ring to the gridiron sexual
assault allegations against former
players of the louisiana state
university football team
have allegedly been swept under the rug
usa today reports
lsu was aware of the allegations and
ignored them
for several years the report says nine
players have had complaints of sexual
misconduct
or violence since head coach ed ogaron
took over the program back in 2016.
running back darius gaius is accused of
raping a member of the lsu diving team
and at least one other woman former wide
receiver drake davis is also accused of
violence
towards his girlfriend and was later
arrested on those allegations
the university responded to usa today's
report saying
they are unwavering in their commitment
to respond promptly
and investigate reports of misconduct
darris guys went on to play the nfl for
washington and he was released
this summer after being arrested on
domestic violence charges
terry sports are no stranger to these
allegations but what's kind of unique
here
is that the school's being dragged into
their part in this and almost
kind of complicity uh what do you make
of these allegations and how it could
affect the university as a whole
you know if a school is receiving
federal funding
they are liable under title ix and they
have to
put policies in place to protect
individuals
from sexual harassment or sexual assault
or rapes
and if they ignore these cases
then they are exposed here and so they
cannot
show a deliberate quote-unquote
indifference so they
absolutely do have some exposure it's
not just the individuals
who are taking part in this it's also
the school who has a responsibility
all right so we got potential federal uh
charges against the school
as you're saying based on title ix well
let's look at some of the individual
players now
some of these allegations were years ago
but we've seen weinstein cosby
people who were accused of crimes
decades ago being taken down by these
sexual assault allegations could these
players who are now in the nfl some of
them
also face a similar fate as to weinstein
and cosby
absolutely brian they could because look
if the statute of limitations allows
these claims to be brought these
individuals
will definitely be exposed to liability
here
and if in fact the victims can come
forward and testify
and if in fact there are several
witnesses who can it will bolster the
case
all right we'll definitely keep an eye
on that again to start with the usa
today but we'll follow that as that case
progresses
in lsu and when we come back a love
triangle a secret recording
and a deadly pizza order led to the
murder and conviction of an ohio woman
now she awaits her fate
[Music]
welcome back an ohio woman was convicted
of helping her then
husband kill his ex over a custody
dispute
we're giving you an inside look into
that disagreement so you can decide
for yourself the defendant's guilt a
jury found erica stefanco
guilty of murder in a plot that involved
a fake pizza order
to lure delivery driver ashley biggs to
her death
in 2012 biggs was fighting over custody
of her daughter
that she shared with stefanko's husband
chad cobb
the seven-year-old says she was in her
father's car at the time of the murder
she's now 15 so we're not going to show
you her face
but she says she remembers hearing the
defendant order a pizza
she was mentally abusive and physically
i remember she would hold me on the
ground and she would hit me
and then she also before made me eat dog
feces
do you know why she made you eat dog
feces
because she was jealous of my
relationship with my father
do you have a memory of erica
making a phone call yes she i can
remember
her and i remember hearing it but not
seeing it
and i know she ordered a pizza
i don't remember what she said that was
on it
and i can remember that she did not use
her name
do you remember what name she did use no
do you know where you were when you
heard this phone call being made
in the back of a car so it was you
you said k.c a.l
erica and was there anyone else
that's all i that's all i recall
remembering seeing
the victim's daughter now lives with her
grandmother chad cobb's mother
on cross the defense asked her if anyone
could have influenced her testimony to
the jury
with respect to particularly your
grandma
have you folks in the past talked about
this case not majorly now in the past
few months have you ever talked about
this
case with your dad no
he's never brought this case up to you
he doesn't really like talking about it
you said there was some good and some
bad yes
did you have some good and bad with your
dad
i always remember good do you know why
your dad is in prison yes why is that
because he did some not so nice things
is it your understanding
that he did some not so nice things
to your mother yes do you still love
your dad
yes i do would you like to see him get
out of prison
soon yeah he's right yes he's my dad
do you think by being here that you're
helping your dad get out of prison
no this isn't his case
the victim's daughter accused defanco of
feeding her feces and abusing her
while she lived with them prosecutors
attempted to clear up
why she was there to testify on redirect
there may be an implication that the
reason you're here
testifying is to get back at erica
for the bad things that you said she did
to you
is that true or not true i want to get
it out there
you want to get what like the truth out
so mr o'brien asked you if the purpose
of you being here
was to help your father and you
indicated it was not
it was not to help your dad see your
siblings so why are you here because
erica
didn't treat me right and nobody really
knew about it
all right so terry it's interesting
during the trial we heard chad cobb say
well i wasn't the one who murdered her
even though he um
was convicted of it and testified to it
at least in open court during that
that uh that guilty plea but
the fact that chad cobb got life do you
think that because he
committed the act that he should get
less jail time than
than stefanko may get you know i think
it's interesting
he got life without parole and i think
erica stefanco might get it's hard to
predict but i think she might get
life with parole i mean obviously the
jury
felt as though she participated in the
murder they brought back a guilty
as far as the murder conviction was
concerned
but i think they understand also that
her role was to make the phone call she
didn't
actually quote unquote you know sort of
pull the trigger so i think they might
give her an
opportunity to get out with parole but
it's hard to say
yeah so he's thinking that life is still
there but the jury might give
them them being the defense maybe parole
the possibility of parole
but do you think that a person is likely
to get parole with such a heinous
crime because it's not an allegation
anymore well you know i think what's
interesting when you
heard the daughter there testifying i
think the fact that stefanko
was so cruel and mean to the daughter
and literally
made her eat feces i think that might
have
some role here as far as and you know
the judge might be
thinking about that the jury might be
thinking about that
the fact that stefanko really should be
punished here so
you know i think that she i do think
she's going to get like
the real question is when will she be up
as far as parole is concerned
all right that's a great question to
think of we'll definitely follow up
terry thank you for joining us
and of course thank you for joining us
here on the law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you